fine we're gonna have to get pretty
physical right now it's been a long time
since I've gotten physical dude don't
even worry about it I brought weapons my
bro Neely's yes okay look check it out I
got slingshot cool I'll take that
well well before your nade longer well I
have something better I have the tetanus
ball it's a tennis ball with rusty nails
in it okay I'm gonna want the slingshot
cuz this looks pretty stupid because
what are you you're supposed to throw it
how are you gonna pick that back up and
you're gonna you're gonna tennis eyes
yourself no see that's what you're not
taking into account I have a protector
Glock that you wear so maybe maybe you
should think that over before he calls
very very smart move but also I will
take the sling shoot well no I don't
think you should because you don't even
know how to sling shoot what did you
just see my practice room well I did and
it didn't look right no it looked pretty
good okay you little ammo so you can
write no fine
ah Adam Adam oh oh my oh my oh god help
uh yeah just give me the slingshot or
not hold the back guys ah ah just
break your neck help my friend is
choking turfs
wait what are you doing here what's your
the cheater yeah I'm the cheer okay at
the store the other day she gave me over
the pants HJ and dude you should have
seen what I did in my pants really
unreal I just like barf out of my finger
no way how many Ounces are we talking
like I like a gushers worth or like
priests on like five busts if I don't
how much you know oh that's why you
weren't in ski pants yeah you're gonna
sustain probably - now I get it
Oh and Adams choking me Stein man gonna
come down are you clogging on what scare
to use your hair here hurry hurry hurry
come on come on here muscles loose now
Oh George just drop this dude thing you
some shrinkage buzzing okay
oh hey baby my little baby little angel
like a big boy yeah
oh oh oh my god I was scary thank you
it's all right sorry
hey I've been alive for 24 years
ever you done anything really
don't say ahem I ever done anything
every jet skied off Warfel no one's you
have ever even audible rollover expenses
if you see the Expendables we did know
your Valentine
whatever the point is I need to do more
badass stuff watch more classic movies
everyone seen feeding the basin like
seven years ago my favorite movie okay
and employed it
you